The fire hydrant that
we know today traces its origins back to fire
plugs.
Water mains that transported fresh water in
a city or town used to be made of hollowed
out logs buried beneath the streets.
Whenever there was a fire and firefighters
needed water, they dug up the cobblestone
street and drilled a hole into the wooden
pipe.
After they extinguished the fire, the firefighters
put a plug in the hole—called a “fire
plug”—before reburying the water main.
The plug could then be removed and the same
hole used if another fire occurred in the
area, saving the drilling time.
One problem with fire plugs, however, was
that digging for them and moving cobblestones
took up valuable firefighting time that should
have been spent putting out a fire.
In addition, the plugs and holes in the water
main were only located in areas where fires
had already occurred.
So firefighters needed to drill new holes
into the water main if they arrived at a fire
in a neighborhood that hadn’t yet experience
a fire.
The introduction of cast-iron water mains
that were much more difficult to drill on
the fly resulted in a solution to the problem.
As the cast-iron water mains slowly replaced
the hollowed out logs and the fire plugs,
taps were extended from the water main to
above the street level and worked like faucets
for firefighters to hook up their hoses.
These taps were also placed at regular intervals
along the street.
Firefighters now had easy access to a reliable
source of water and in predictable locations.
In 1801, Frederick Graff, Sr. is generally
credited with inventing the fire hydrant that
resembles the fire hydrants we know today.
Known as the “post” or “pillar” design,
these hydrants gave firefighters access to
the water through a hose/faucet outlet.
They also had a valve on the top of the hydrant.
The design allowed water to flow into the
hydrant at all times, a type of hydrant that
would later be known as a “wet-barrel”
hydrant because it always had water flowing
into it.
Wet barrel fire hydrants like Graff’s still
exist today, though their design means that
they are only used in warmer climates.
Areas subject to the ground freezing in winter
use dry-barrel hydrants.
Unlike wet barrel hydrants which allow water
into the hydrant at all times, the dry-barrel
hydrant does not.
While there are variations on the design,
in general, the dry-barrel hydrant connects
with a water main buried beneath the frost
line, the depth to which the ground typically
freezes in the winter.
This connection includes a pair of valves,
the main valve and the drain valve.
When opened, the main valve sends water into
the fire hydrant and the drain valve is automatically
closed.
The drain valve automatically opens when the
main valve is shut.
It then allows the water to drain out of the
hydrant and back into the water main without
allowing any water back in, so that the hydrant
isn’t full of water which would freeze during
cold winter temperatures.
While the design of dry-barrel fire hydrants
make them unlikely to freeze during winter,
they can still fail.
Either the main valve or the drain valve might
stop working if they are not maintained properly
or need to be replaced due to old age.
Other times, a dry-barrel hydrant may freeze
because an unusually cold winter could move
the frost line deeper in the ground and cause
problems with the water main, potentially
damaging the valves in the process.
This is why during the winter, you will often
see crews out testing the hydrants to make
sure there aren’t any freezing problems.
After using a dry-barrel hydrant, firefighters
will also often notify the appropriate utility
company to let them know, so that if they
so choose they can come out and make sure
the hydrant drained properly.
According to the Director of Distribution
at the South Bend, Indiana Water Department,
how they
the check is as follows: